non-minimalists
how do i step back from obligations i've
always
done in the past i struggle to change
when i've said yes many times before and
it's become an assumption
now during the lightning round for those
of you who are new this is where ryan
and i do our best to answer questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response
you can put the text of those minimal
maxims in the show notes so we can
people can copy and share your pithy
answers or our pithy answers on
on social media and um all of our mental
maxims are in one place now minimal
maxims.com thanks jess
uh nick let me say this here's my pithy
answer for you maybe we can expand on it
maybe we won't i have two pithy answers
for you because i'm
twice as pithy minimalist
change happens not from how often we say
yes
but when we say yes to only that which
propels us toward our destination
there's a lie we've been told ryan it's
not about the destination man
it's about the journey
well that's nonsense like well yeah
yeah keep going without with no you're
good let's talk about it without without
the destination there would be no
journey
that is correct but the yeah so the the
the the destination plays a role right
they both play a role
in both play role yes and so by the way
you didn't go on a journey this morning
when you drove to the studio
right you had a destination in mind and
then the journey resulted because there
was a a destination
right there right here's my other pit
the answer for you you can copy and
share this if you'd like
no is the most freeing word in the world
it is often the most compassionate too
honest i think we don't realize ryan
that sometimes
we say yes because we're afraid
of saying no but that's not being
compassionate if you're doing something
for someone that you don't want to do
that's not compassion
yeah that is um that is cowardice
and we've all experienced i know i've
done it a million times over and i'm
sorry a million times for that it's
funny how we talk ourselves
into doing things that make us miserable
for the sake of virtue
going back to that word yes um
but if you're doing something just for
the sake of being virtuous then
it's kind of not virtuous right exactly
it was i think it was lal zoo
who said the most uh uh
like all virtue was not virtuous he has
some quote like that
um and and really what he's saying is
we're doing something
to if we're doing something to be
virtuous it's not virtuous
it's not virtuous right yeah and that's
okay too i've got
one and a half pithy answers all right
uh the answer i wrote down for this uh
is boulders can be set down as easily as
they
were picked up and it's funny because i
sent milburn this
um spoiler alert i send him everything i
write for him to edit and shape
so i do that to sean right right i'm
your sean
yeah so uh melbourne responded back and
he said well
maybe it would be a little bit punchier
or more powerful
if it's easier to set down a than a
boulder down
than it is to pick it up yes and i was
like well actually if anything i would
think it's the opposite
well let's think about it in real life
there's a boulder in that corner much
yes yeah and really yeah yeah physically
yes obviously gravity is going to be
much easier going down than up
but these metaphorical boulders it's
difficult to pick up
because they are burdens there are
obligations they are things that
uh if we don't do then we're gonna we're
gonna not feel virtuous
so it's very hard to pick up that
boulder and to follow through with
carrying it but then to put it down
it's equally as hard yes because we are
we feel like we're letting someone else
down
we're feeling like we're not being
virtuous if we put that boulder down
so that's why to me it might even be
harder sometimes
to say no but the only way you get good
at it is by
practicing right um the other pithy
answer i have that i thought of
uh had that had that men's group meeting
last night men's team meeting last night
and someone said you cannot prioritize
your commitments there's no such thing
as prioritizing your commitments
and that's for me it rings true here
because either you're committed or
you're not you can't see
you can't have a list of 10 commitments
and be like well here are the important
ones like if you've committed you've
committed yeah and so maybe another way
to say that is you can't prioritize your
desires right because if you have a deep
desire to do something it's either
greater than your desire to do this like
if you want to play
you beau jackson played what football
and baseball right yes
and and and so like if you have a if you
could only choose
one baseball a lot of people are this
way right were they they were two sport
athletes
and they had to choose one well it's
whatever the greater desire was
it wasn't a checklist of commitments and
pros and cons and all those things can
be helpful for the most mechanical level
but they can't help us understand our
desire
right let me add an additional uh
minimal maximum for you ryan this is
because i like what you said about the
boulder
and so maybe what was my answer that you
it's easier to set down a boulder than
it is to pick it up
literally quite literally it is yeah
yeah right literally but so maybe
instead of pick it up we
we say carry it forever
it is easier to set down a boulder than
it is to carry it forever yeah you can
tweet that podcast
that's good